depuis les résultats des législatives en
octobre la tunisie était en quête d'un
gouvernement
lors de ces élections ennahda arrive en
tête mais n'obtient pas la majorité
absolue le parti d'inspiration islamiste
n'est donc pas en mesure de jouer le
rôle pivot sur la scène politique auquel
il prétend conséquences en janvier le
précédent gouvernement constitué par
ennahdha échoue à obtenir la confiance
des députés
c'est pas une déception c'est une
réussite de la démocratie tunisienne
voilà un gouvernement que celle qui se
présente à la rp il sera elle est
arrivée au parlement sans avoir une
majorité
donc quand on arrive sans avoir une
majorité vous savez ce qui arrive on a
perdu deux mois un désaveu devant
l'assemblée des représentants des
peuples qui pousse le président tunisien
à reprendre la main cai sayed désigne
alors eliès par phare pour former un
nouveau gouvernement
un choix risqué puisque son parti
ettakatol ne compte aucun député dans
l'actuel parlement
mais la semaine dernière et lyes farfar
trouvent un accord de dernière minute
avec ennahdha première force
parlementaire sans surprise son
gouvernement ont obtenu jeudi la
confiance du parlement tunisien mettant
fin à une incertitude politique mais le
travail du chef du gouvernement pourrait
s'avérer très difficile et complexe avec
un cabinet hétéroclite qui comprend des
membres aux idéologies et aux visions
différentes
quant aux tunisiens plus de neuf ans
après avoir chassé ben ali lors du
printemps arabe et les attendent
toujours un gouvernement capable
d'affronter les maux sociaux et
économiques qui rongent leurs pays
[Musique]